des rues calmes et pourtant les
commerçants du centre-ville nourrissent
de grands espoirs
cette période de soldes arrivent juste
après le manque à gagner des fêtes de
fin d'année dû en partie à la grève des
transports publics
du coup les stocks sont importants il
faut absolument les écouler et les
rabais risque d'être plus intéressant
cette année dans le commerce aujourd'hui
ce qui est perdu est perdu est très
difficile à rattraper ce qu'on attend
c'est simplement que les clients
reviennent nous voir en tout cas en
centre-ville pour profiter des soldes un
petit peu plus forte que d'habitude
parce que parce qu'on a un peu plus de
stock
voilà donc on casse un peu plus fort on
fait rentrer plus tôt si la nouvelle
collection essayer d'apporter plus de
séduction donc on attend tout simplement
qu'il vienne avec régularité et pas
juste sur un vendredi et un samedi matin
et voilà c'est le centre ville est
agréable on prend un parapluie au cas où
et ça peut bien se passer dans plusieurs
grandes enseignes on affiche déjà des
-70 % et la deuxième démarque sera
appliquée mercredi au bout d'une semaine
au lieu de 10 jours habituellement je
trouve que les prix sont intéressants
mais je débute à peine donc on va voir
les sols n'ont jamais profité des soldes
non non pas du tout cette année vous
allez essayer je vais essayer on va voir
ce que ça donne qu'est ce que vous
pensez des prix qui sont pratiqués cette
année pour ce que ce que j'ai déjà vu
c'est pas trop mal et motivé cette fois
merci le vrai challenge pour les
commerçants sera d'attirer un maximum de
personnes vers le centre ville
vraiment les russes étaient assez vide
est bon comme je communique sur
instagram et facebook sur les réseaux
sociaux
du coup les clients savent qu'il ya de
la nouveauté donc elles font l'effort de
venir mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident disons qu'on essaie découler
faire des petits des prix intéressants
les attirer donc on fait en sorte de les
quitter les soldes se termineront le 19
février prochain plus qu'une semaine
pour faire de bonnes affaires avant la
mise en place officielle des nouvelles
collections